back to the two-hand slam that was a  strong move by buck Booker because he  had like two three hands on that ball  and he was able to get that bounce pass  over to Baines synthesis for books third  double-double of the season well you  hear the chants of defense that's what  it is all about Moran on the drone and  just it rocks over the top of Bay's for  the right hand slam my goodness  three on the way no Baines has got it a  wrestling match ensues and a rant still  talking to Aron Baynes John Marin how  quick he gets up and slams it down over  veins and he shifted it into his right  hand he went with the left and put it  into his right and shifting gears and  just explodes to the basket  [Music]